britney spears firing back at ex-husband
kevin federline better line yeah britney
spears better line in a new interview
with the uk's itv the former backup
dancer makes some unexpected allegations
involving their two sons sean preston
and jaden james kevin claims the boys
have decided they're staying away from
their mom right now and it's been a few
months since they've even seen brittany
i love being a mom he also says their
kids made the decision not to go to her
wedding with sam as gary citing her
suggestive instagram posts as part of
their reasoning and britt wasn't having
it in a lengthy message shared to
instagram she wrote it saddens me to
hear that my ex-husband has decided to
discuss the relationship between me and
my children they're really confused with
mommy the star and
and mommy you know so it's really
interesting to see they're like is that
britney spears or is that you mommy i'm
like it's the same person
it's really sweet the pop icon took
particular issue with kevin's claim
about her risque social media posts
writing as we all know raising teenage
boys is never easy for anyone do they
think it's but you get any like cool
points for being britney spears like as
mom
i guess sometimes i don't i'm not sure
brick goes on to imply any issues came
about when her conservatorship was still
in place and long before any sexy pics
on the gram this is the happiest time of
our lives and we're just enjoying it and
sam echoes her feelings in a story of
his own there is no validity to his
statement regarding the kids distancing
themselves and it is irresponsible to
make that statement publicly sam ends
his response with an infamous phrase we
know all too well in 2022 i wish him the
best and hope he has a more positive
outlook in the future for the benefit of
all involved but for now
keep my wife's name out of your mouth
on-camera segments from kevin's
interview are expected to be released in
the near future
you